this is secret team I just want to say
make a very important announcement I
made fun of myself for watch cartoons
the last episode I don't want that going
on my record I think cartoons are
awesome God knows like when this is
release will be 24 hours and Christ
knows the comment so probably thick
people let's cut your time now watch it
but nobody will know me well yeah now
the only good then now I said yeah and
there'll be no apology in the next one
so I'll be fucked see that's the problem
with doing these so far in advance
if I pushing the boulder up the hill it
just never always comes rolling down God
take the apology back I was gonna say I
like watching cartoons I had no problem
people don't watch cartoons by I'm
fucking sorry for making the joke
especially helps with your page oh that
is a bonus and that is what if you are
gonna watch cartoons and not get paid
whatever you want to do in the privacy
of your own time seems more savory than
other things some people do in their
spare time so or private I um but a fair
time is private I guess it's you always
could spend spare time with friends
people what are those tell you when you
grow up
um know that this was a fun episode what
I really like about this one is that you
know with every episodes of show should
do you feel more of a connection a
community between them and in a strange
way something about keeping a secret
from one of them especially because of
intimidation stuff like that even though
they trust her and she's the leader in
stuff like that but so you want to keep
a secret that felt very real for some
reason and just a secret
instead of pizza say VI pizza secret uh
and something about that just made them
feel a little bit more believable that
it's I donno is she's a leader and we
get them we're totally fine with that
stuff there's just some things we don't
want to get in trouble for it I want to
push we don't want to roll messin with
roses things uh yeah I'm still stand by
there's some kind of connection there
I don't know what direction they're
going to but like the look in her eyes
when she's like not only what you like
you know I just want to see how reacted
with the bulb of the women I don't know
you got bring over the eyes whether they
were just friends or like mo yeah um but
yeah there's something definitely there
uh then I feel they're building up um oh
what and even with that though like I
really love again I just any time garnet
enters a seed especially if it's like a
silly scene I just start to crack up cuz
she's just I think it's just so Elsa
it's so cool to shake and like when she
comes in after you know he wants to get
the secret team back together he's going
through his you know whatever is oh the
good old days and stuff even though
wasn't even a day ago and just when he
calls her into the pizza joy that she
just sits down all right what is this
about just and just slightly tired and
you just she just always has this look
like her just pizza pizza I think this
was you know she just has everything
like you know our control but she's also
like kind of doing you know the majority
of the work and she you know has the
heaviest load to carry and stuff like
that and you just see her that she's
she's being called in for this stupid
secret team thing and just see her
they're like you like I said there's
just that presence she just sits down
all right what's this about like she's
ready she's right Bryce ready to see
what's going on then he's and he's ready
to bust for something that clearly is
not that important uh but then turns out
to kind of be important too and again
she always has like the right answer for
it and everything so well that um and I
thought was very clever the way they
built out that one the charge could
still be missing the arm and then you
can't forget about and then it comes
back and that turns out it wasn't
missing that was garnet doing a trick uh
and I with I just wanted to have the Sam
Raimi sounds from Evil Dead my fat
burger uh and I like that was her the
whole time and I especially like as you
said like amethyst and pearl were not
going to stand up say no was me they're
just like oh my god what I'm bitching
which again shows I was like holy shit
they're totally gonna let him take the
photo but again it sort of does ask a
question like what kind of yeah what is
going on with that because either garnet
really has this controller this harsh
hand on it but doesn't seem to because
she comes around and it's my tactical
ability but pearl seems to be the brain
half the time
well amethyst has brought over Oh like I
I know I don't never everybody fits in
this it's either her control over it or
more what I'm thinking that whatever was
in that bubble was such a huge thing you
know and anything connected Rose was
like such a huge fan even anthesis was
like oh no oh crap like this is really
badly we should we cannot tell Guardian
I guess I oh I got your hands to me yeah
so I mean but uh but we don't know I
mean for them to not even like take the
responsibility for that cuz they usually
do not seem like that sneaky in terms of
cast I especially like Stephen get it I
was just sitting there watching it I was
like you weren't saving horse how dare
you oh I couldn't believe it
and the the animation - I mean just the
little details for some reason I really
felt kinda like the video game presence
in this one like with the whip I was
really feeling like Castlevania well the
soundtrack was early attack was much
more video game II than usual I'm
addicted you know little touches like
how do you explain to an anime okay the
hand has purl and then it goes bang it
spins her like this she's and look at
this we're gonna yeah facing right yeah
it's like how do you even explain that
but they like animated beautifully and
it was really all put together
um um and I think there is something
funny against even just wanting to feel
that connection more more cuz they are
gone a lot you know I mean they're on
notice till miss em or so then the rooms
have their own kind of like individual
music attached to it because it was
somewhere in pearls ever I'm just like
she has like this piano thing going
where it's like this soft like and I'm
like yeah I guess they're all
really individualized right down to the
music that plays in the room well and I
love seeing the rooms again too because
we saw that in that one episode it's
like oh like this will be fun and then
they kind disappear and it's nice having
them back again cuz I forgots like yeah
these are now are they nice designs but
they have such personality to each room
uh you know like it was matching pearls
room I'm like I can I can just go to
sleep in this room like it's a heavily
that was my room just these giant
waterfalls and stuff like we didn't rip
these things up we could have a whole
free pizza that's a great final job oh I
was kind of thinking that as they were
like Pez I'm like was good pizza um but
uh yeah I like that line too so the only
time you two can work together is what
I'm threatening to kill you I'm like
that's how most teams work in that um
but again I think there's like there's
always that one person that it's just
like no no I can't piss them off yeah
all right fine I'll work together yes
um but again there was something
surprisingly like I said about keeping
it away from them it's like they become
more than just hey just this character
in this character working off for each
other and I'm only the individual it's
kind nice when they had to come together
on a goal what you caught we always call
it the alliance of convenience the
Alliance of I I always was one of my fav
as if we were talking about how a couple
episodes ago the faking an injury plot
trope or whatever is one of my least
favorite the Alliance of convenience is
actually one of my favorite tropes I
just love people I love it too normally
would never get together to accomplish a
goal are forced out of just pure
convenience or some other power to come
together to accomplish something and
then normally right after they've
accomplished that it completely falls
apart and and you had to do it sparingly
though cause like on did you ever watch
parks and recreations no it's you should
it's a good show uh but the one thing
that got oh it's like the one criticism
I have of the show is that there's only
like all these characters are so
well-defined and I mean it's like a cast
of Simpsons characters I mean they're
just so great and you're always looking
forward to seeing work off each other
but there's in the latest seasons
especially they starts they like in
every episode you can count how many
times ago I don't usually do this but in
sir sentimental moment and that's what
the Alliance it can be
we go away to my dad a lot no the office
was really I don't like the office I'm
just putting it out there I don't like
the office Barzeh Frank is so much
better i I'm indifferent to the office
so oh yeah I and it's not like if you
like it's like what's wrong with you no
I get I get the attraction I just never
liked it um but yeah but that is like
the one thing I'd show it made me
realize like because I love that trope
to them the alliance of convenience but
it can be done too much - it has to be
done sparingly like in x-men - I love it
when magneto has to work making you a
mystique have to work with Wolverine and
G that stuff like like I love that I
love it's like they have to how well
again work together how lit again gel
off each other how well they not going
to work together you know that kind of
stuff is always great and even it's just
something as small as a team that's
supposed to work together anyway you
know pro and amethyst
uh it's still great to see it it's great
zoom work off of me yeah one of our
favorite movies the Great Race yeah that
happens right smack dab in the movie
when they're forced to survive by
huddling up together basically the
villain and the hero open together
Miyazaki films have the ability of
convenience so uh yeah just I don't know
that's a thing a limey I don't know if
that's like the name it should be the
name cuz whatever names right ya know
whatever name is out there that's just
such a much better name um so that's
always what we called our stars good
name um but anywho yeah uh I thought was
a fun episode if I was uh a gay you
learn may not word but you feel like
just mores going I like I said
especially with rose and I feel like
really we've been more plot heavy but
maybe that's just me they I felt like
I've got so I don't well I feel like
I've gotten more out of the episodes at
least that if it's a filler episode I
feel like I got more bad - okay yeah
that I can see where if it's a filler
episode it's like they're putting enough
stuff that's like oh that's interesting
like yeah learning quad heavy ism what I
should say but I feel like I'm taking
more out of it yeah
even if it's not like oh here's some
linear story yeah okay that makes sense
yeah I'm feeling that - um oh I feel
like being with a helmet you look at
love it love it
oh that's some more good let's do it
because we're grown men who like to
watch cartoons what's mmm
and garnet and pearl and Steven
we said it twice I got nothing extra
okay shut up